[Music]
in genius idea news mm-hmm submitted by
accidental airdrop Oh Nick Nick cuz
accident I said it like it was there's
an end you said all the titles like that
the world is gonna do that the world's
first hotel for houseplants has just
yeah I want to see all the plants wait
so if you go on vacation you can leave
your house plants there like that yes
that's a lot you gotta have a truck
though that's how many plants you have
oh yeah
she has a guard waiting a big old pot
right the bottom right yeah so this
hotel is exclusively for house plants so
they'll take care of your weed plants
for you you got like three big ones
leave other I don't know the merry pot
dude that's how your plants get a
venereal disease though like like spider
mites or something they get it from
other plants you gotta be really careful
I don't know how many other people's
plants is gonna be in the same same room
as my plan might affect that's getting
bedbugs so this is called the patch
plant hotel and they are now open for
bookings and they said that they have
100 rooms up for grabs to accommodate
your indoor or outdoor plants depending
on climate yeah and that they will take
care of uh they'll be taken care of by a
team of specialists making sure that
they're hydrated and that they have food
like plant food and I picture it being
like a regular hotel room will you walk
in and there's just a fern sitting on
the bed you know this staff is just like
moms you shared moms love it thank you
and they bring the room service things
that I opens up it's just like a little
watering thing there's like a tray with
a little mini watering can and in a vs.
hands is like cutting that
[Music]
[Applause]
so you're the promotional photos what if
it really looks like that [ __ ] hotel
budapest by david beckham is [ __ ] the
what is it bellboy mm-hmm my eyes are
really bad that just looks like a
nursery you see this this is how they
get diseases that's inhumane i thirty
see all those plants squished together
refugees that's not free-range plant no
that's not free-range plan at all
it looks like plant trafficking to me
that kind of looks gb GMO high plant
needs a private room where's the natural
sunlight this is a hostel this is a
plant hostel yeah it's not a hotel yeah
I don't know I wonder what the rates are
oh that guy looks kind of like he wants
to make love to those plants I mean he
looks like a plant [ __ ] you know dude
have you seen the SNL skit with Chris
what Christopher Walken or he has to put
googly eyes on the plant it's my
favorite pitch you mean like those
chicken yeah he's like I need to be able
to look on the eyes otherwise I can't
trust them I trust this one we're
friends I can see that this one I don't
know but I can't even I don't know about
that one it looks down on I can't he
plays it so well you have to look it up
google it google it
anyway yeah I don't know how much the
room rates are but I mean if you if you
leave for a month I mean somebody gotta
water your plan that's exactly why
people are saying like this is [ __ ]
genius because now Millennials like they
they're lazy way more plant loving yeah
than previous generation I've been like
in style
I thought that was a grandma thing it
was but it came back in style cuz
mid-century modern our mid-century style
came back as like mid-century modern and
so a lot of that is plants and stuff
people don't know the bottle technique
oh yeah they don't yeah you just get
like a bottle and then like let's say
you drill a little hole and then like
however long you only last for a week
and put a gallon and just put a little
it just constantly have a little drip a
little drip thing and then you don't
have to well I guess also in London it's
during winter months there's snow and
stuff outside yes all your plants will
die but I guess in California we have a
kid
you have a good yeah don't worry about
over here yeah so I mean I don't know a
lot of people are are really digging
this idea because people take vacations
especially over there they they have a
lot of holidays and so they don't have
to bug their family or friends to water
their plants while they're gone I'd be
scared about the liability cuz like
people go probably just talking for a
friend
people are protective of their plants
and maybe if they pick up the plant and
it has like a bacteria or it has like
some brown leaves I'd be like who hurt
you
where did they touch you I think you
time for a friend I thought you were
talking for a friend I mean my friend
would be like unless it's a bonsai tree
you know it's probably like I'll sue you
for $40 because my plant died and you
bought it for $40 you know I love plants
so much like the look of it and all but
every time I try buying a plant for
myself I always die you have to research
because different plants need different
waterings and different types of dirt
and sunlight and how often they water
yeah in sunlight so if your house
doesn't get that much light you'd be
better off with like certain kinds of
plants and I just totally just gave up
on the dream of being a plant owner
because my cats just go in if I have any
fresh dirt the Lynx dig it up oh [ __ ] my
favorite part of owning plants is
fertilizing them with your piss yeah if
I could pee and pull up the class is
like my favorite Deena did you know that
the you know people that live really
really long people live to be like 110
years old the number one most common
thing that they have that they all have
is gardening okay like please don't tell
them that did [ __ ] shooting in prison
and eating them there's something about
taking care of plants nice to pee on my
tomato pal all the time I've never seen
any tomatoes as well as a kid like what
you guys get it to me
and cucumbers at pumpkins you know we
had tomatoes garlic yeah yeah tomatoes
and garlic right and they taste like
when you open love I had a lot of herbs
but those if you don't water them every
day they die so we went on one vacation
and they work on herbs needle this would
have been perfect for you I want to
thank some herbs I got a big tree I got
a Hummer granite tree I got an apple
tree I got orchard I got a lot of yeah
it's a big-ass backyard huge an urban
high that's one of the winning points of
why I got the house I was like oh my god
I need a fruit tree so there's so many
you get fruits all the time [ __ ]
avocados ooh you get rats and [ __ ] no oh
I wouldn't know you'll know because your
fruits all be like chumki chomped off
maybe possums I found a dead possum baby
possum yeah oh they're cute they are
cute
it was grow my friend had a baby possum
and cheek raised it and stuff and it was
super cute it would just like sit on her
and like cuddle with her nasty no
they're cute no they're actually I think
marsupials I'm sorry I don't know but I
read they're not like that they're not
pets they are like I think marsupials
and that made them that makes them cuter
to me you know they're not in depth to
California yeah you know how they got
here to California possums yes so
they're actually like so like like the
people the poor people that were moving
to California like ordering the Oregon
Trail and all that [ __ ] they would just
pick them up on their [ __ ] roadtrip
and that was there like iqbal food oh oh
I wouldn't because they're easy to catch
and find and whatever right so they're I
think they're from the the south or what
or lose yet or what I think you could
catch a possum in the video game Oregon
Trail yeah I always went for the Buffalo
but yeah my grandpa used to set up traps
and and he yeah everything about it
a little yeah I mean our pigs appetizing
looking they look disgusting
they all do they look like humans
chickens all look crazy there mom you
think about a possum like incoming in
comparison to like a squirrel they're
like big and fat they're probably yeah I
still try to that's what people do they
put them in cages and then there'll be
[ __ ] riding to California and [ __ ]
and some of them get loose and all that
and then they populate I thought that
the squirrels I don't know about
squirrels but that's how I found out
about possums because when we found a
possum in my backyard I'll start doing
research
I almost shaped like they're almost
shape like those like swarm of things
it's been around some on a PITA so like
back in the day before grocery stores
everyone had to like get and grab their
food and that's not even it's like our
grandparents times right like so so like
grandparents and great-grandparents that
live in the outback or like mom up in
the [ __ ] forest and Shinya to me like
grocery store yeah so did my great-great
grandmother and great-grandmother
instant
great-grandma in the forest that they
didn't have a farmers market to go to
right if they lived in the camp cabins
and [ __ ] and if they were Lumberjacks
how do they get their food it wasn't and
were Lumberjacks my grandpa it wasn't
that long before that great maybe two
maybe two greats my dad's mom definitely
was I was from the country and had to
[ __ ] break they just had to [ __ ]
hunt whatever the [ __ ] they could get
yeah my fault you know grandma she did
the rice paddy thing but my white
grandma she definitely took grocery
store so far removed now we're so far
removed from the killing of our own meat
that way yeah I stepped on a bee the
other day and I got all sad and I'm like
later that night I'm just devouring
chicken and honey sometimes I feel bad
when I bite the head off a chicken
nugget the head dinosaur chicken nugget
he bites that of a t-rex and he's like I
ain't got a soul Oh
let's talk wings no idea really what are
you chicken no I've been
garyun for like three years because of
that after watching all those
documentaries I'm like I can't do it
anymore I just there's too much of a
connection now I can't not see the image
when you go to a barbecue smell the
smoke yeah that's what I do like that I
don't know like the sauce more the sauce
smells like that and you could put the
sauce on anything so you don't like to
smell it cook meat um I don't know I
guess Rimbaud never lived without it so
I don't I don't know the difference I
don't know if I chose like that
preference but um but like vegan burgers
taste exactly I didn't really like
burgers to begin with so like vegan
burgers taste the same to me but I
realize it doesn't taste the same to
everybody but oh wait I just never
really liked burgers
yeah faux meats for me when I was
vegetarian like oh they got a lot better
though maybe yeah cuz a lot of fat just
carry it now Carl's jr. has it if you
just lean up beyond burger at home and
it was nothing
I like the baked burgers that are made
out of like black bean buns rather than
like just like straight it looks like
it's like a bean patty but when fire
hits protein no matter what animal it is
doesn't it smell good to you guys hell
yeah my roommate has been a vegan for
like 10 years and he says he still likes
that smell it depends on the person too
though it's like she said it's like the
sauce I think when he always said it's
really that's true cuz and then what I'm
like fish smell you got some people
don't like that so even whatever beef
smell could turn people off but then
yeah sometimes the smell is just
nostalgia too because like I remember
going to like baseball games are like
events with my parents so it's not even
like oh I want that meat it's like oh
it's nostalgic it's like hearing a John
Cougar Mellencamp song y'all know John
Carmela not the right crowd okay so you
know the [ __ ] jacket never a Jack and
Diane his little ditty yeah
and the way this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]